we have breaking news overnight in
Germany where police arrested at least
25 people tied to an alleged right-wing
plot to overthrow the government the
targeted groups ideology is similar to
that of far-right groups here in the U.S
Charlie dagada has the latest on this
unfolding story Charlie good morning
good morning to you Nate whether or not
a clear and present danger to the German
state it was serious enough to launch 3
000 officers including Special Forces to
round up those suspects in early morning
raids 130 raids all across the country
with two more people arrested in Austria
and Italy by authorities there German
officials say they were plotting to
storm the Parliament building seized
power and formed their own government
even installing this man Prince Heinrich
the 13th which I think you'll see in a
minute seen here during his arrest as
their leader prosecutors described the
far-right group as reichsberger they're
called reichsberger citizens of the
Reich is being influenced by the
conspiracy group Q Anon now we're told
many of those arrested are ex-military
heavily armed and actively recruiting
more members at least one person in the
group is accused of trying to contact
the Russian government about the plan
Kremlin said this morning this is a
German problem with no Russian
involvement Tony
very scary stuff Charlie dagada for us
in London Charlie thank you very much